[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président je vous remercie
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
hier le président de la république qui a
été reçu par les maires dans le meilleur
esprit républicain
il leur a rendu hommage le contraire
aurait surpris mais il a laissé le
chantier de l'acte iii de la
décentralisation en jachère sans rien
annoncé de neuf ans les nuages
s'accumulent sur les libertés locales
la recentralisation est en marche qui
place les communes sous la dépendance de
l'état et déresponsabilise les élus
l'autonomie financière recule devant l'
usine à gaz la compensation de la taxe
d'habitation
les dotations s'érode
car elles ne sont pas indexés sur
l'inflation
les subventions discrétionnaire des
préfets sont préférés à la dotation
d'investissement qui seul est libre
d'emplois à travers les contrats de
cahors l'état s'immisce dans la libre
administration des collectivités
il oppose une fin de non recevoir au
rééquilibrage des relations entre
communes et intercommunalités rien n'est
fait pour faire obstacle au
communautarisme
sur ce point on sait maintenant ce dont
le président ne veut pas mais on ne sait
toujours pas ce qu'il veut alors
monsieur le premier ministre
allez-vous prendre la pleine mesure de
ses réalités et des menaces d' asphyxie
qui pèsent sur la démocratie locale
[Applaudissements]